[Music]
in burger fail news
oh no submitted by Jalisco number one we
sit with the James what's bigger Holly
is Jalisco in Guadalajara or Valera and
javis playing the Los Angeles is in Cali
for California yeah that one with
Jalisco state Jalisco Jalisco is
California yeah
what about Corona because I saw it when
I was driving in Tijuana
what a nice like up north dude like
right now we're on our way there's no
beer no like in the city in in Mexico
court all out I don't know all of them I
saw the sign when I was longer than any
less true the city of Modelo Tecate I'm
not eating and drinking hey you can't
eat yeah no yeah you can drink to clear
my throat but not when you're about to
why did you give him the green light to
drink you know you said to clear my
feeling this way though I drink all the
time place it into one of these brands
just kidding films that big cartel calm
believe below you could get one mug we
misspelled John F Kennedy 22 burger
chains were given an F rating for using
beef from cows raised with antibiotics
what what's the problem I mean I always
surprise isn't that the norm yeah wait I
am surprised that's the norm isn't it
yeah but it shouldn't be the norm cuz
that's disgusting that just means
they're conditioned the living
conditions are really really really what
I thought that all beef that rouses
antibiotic yeah unless specified every
beef that we eat well do like she is
right so that
being though the main reason why this is
bad it's because they're creating these
like these type of diseases so like
whenever we keep your viruses whenever
we get sick our bodies are not receiving
the antibiotics the same way because
we're so used to consuming anywhere
right antibiotics isn't everything that
we want anymore antibiotics anymore so
then like humans are at risk of
developing life-threatening infections
because they're they're having these
bacterial resistance to antibiotics and
it's only for fast foods then well
that's the specific thing that they were
looking into person in every supermarket
but what I don't understand is that how
come these they got hit but like all the
other restaurants didn't get is failing
them I'll tell you all right so I know
the antibiotic Santa antibiotics [ __ ]
community all right so this report is
called chain reaction for burger
addition and it was produced by the
Center for Food Safety
Consumer Reports food animal concerns
trust us PRG Education Fund Friends of
the Earth and National Resources Defense
Council thank you in and out okay those
are all the people involved in this so
this is the graving here yeah what's the
other star there you go just the point
you love so much what a burger
Oh your in and out is right guys
actually shake shake Shack's our best
king sonic jack-in-the-box
what is this Hardee's water burger cause
jr. five guys wait Hardee's is the
Carl's jr. why are they jacking nothing
nothing on that surprises me except for
Wendy where can you go back why is
Wendy's a great above it like I like
kind of goes ad mine yeah we're seeing
and was good what's uh what's what's
that thing next to Shake Shack it's a I
never heard of that cuz man no I love
Shake Shack though that's just delicious
the burgers over the weekend all the
burgers are too that's why you get to
now do that shit's expensive you get to
that's a $30 yeah it was mad but you
know why it was all worth it it was $30
but it's not the same and look they got
an A and if there was a plus they
probably would have got that [ __ ] turn
true
so Wendy's received a D - because 15% of
their beef is sourced from producers
that cut the use of an antibiotic by 1/5
oh I thought it was cause 15% of their
beef was actually born whatever Taco
Bell was doing because like they had
that big thing where they were like oh
now we're using real beef ever you know
I know what I will say this that once
all these people here change their [ __ ]
it's gonna be how expensive yep
everybody complains about the price but
I'm like thank you cuz I could taste the
quality ingredients it's not sad cow
would you guys rather my problem would
you guys rather eat cow with antibiotics
in it or would you rather eat a sick cow
no cuz I'm proud to keep the price low
right so I'm trying to keep the price
low so on his fans a healthy a non
antibiotic cow is gonna be Shake Shack
prices right yeah what if like let's say
we're trying to keep the price low would
you rather have a cow full of
antibiotics or would you rather have the
six cow meat which one has a higher
chance of getting me sick like yeah is
it is it like is it like the cow got a
flu or they got mad cow we're gonna eat
mad cow I know that's why like you're
gonna do I know antibiotics doesn't cure
it but I'm just saying like how sick are
we talking about here the pneumonia a
scowl yeah I could either if a cow's got
a cold I could eat that cow if that cow
what I'll do to you though it's i I've
eaten [ __ ] up vegetables vegetables
there's some counterintuitive there you
wanna antibiotic-free healthy cow body
[ __ ] rotten food mold off the cheese
out give up food I mean all the cheese
that's cuz if you boil the [ __ ] out of
the cow right even if that fool got the
flu wouldn't it boil the flu out the
mother funny like just this like cold
briquette was like very good all that
all the burgers we get from there
they're all well done anyways yeah I
think it's for like bacterial infections
that can go into your body and give you
an infection probably that's what the
antibiotics are for so like you know for
virus and [ __ ] like that I think [ __ ]
boil it out depending on what kind but
me I'm not eating this stuff every day
either yeah I mean it's not like I'm
eating McDonald's every day yeah I'm not
eating these fast foods like honor even
a consistent basis to be honest with you
like I had last time I in and out was
like a month ago
yeah so that's like they are saying cuz
you know how they were saying that
antibiotics isn't everything we a real
problem so that's why they're greedy got
a secret for not an antibiotic stuff
they have all that [ __ ] they have the
labels on this stuff no yeah yeah yeah
so they're saying that each year in the
u.s. at least two million people get an
antibiotic resistant infection and at
least 23,000 people will die damn have
you heard of super gonorrhea no there's
super gonorrhea now from cows nah but in
calls you know it's like same reason
people are abusing antibiotics and then
they're getting super gonorrhea because
they like have a little sex and then
they're like okay well I gotta be on the
antibiotics and then they don't finish
the whole thing and then so like they
still got the gonorrhea 'z and they
still [ __ ] butts but now they gotta I
like the way you say super dude like if
if they mean some yeah yeah they need
some marketing for it he needs to say
the super part is a super super
gonorrhea but if you eat Shake Shack
then you
super gonorrhea I just what Shake Shack
was just a little less so so expensive
or so expensive or if they made the
burgers just a little bit you have it
it's good window that's all there's one
in downtown LA there's no no you cannot
postmates it it's not the same part ruin
it yeah it's not don't do that ever done
that never do that nope it's not any
good burger though it's gonna be like
over ten bucks
like a good ass burger it even wants to
cook it for us every time I don't know
here's the thing about antibiotics
though it's like the reason why they do
it the way that they do is because whole
entire you know what do you call it
flocks of cattle can go far enough herds
yeah herds yes they can all cook and die
an entire pride of cattle yeah [ __ ]
flying gaggle of cat if they all die or
if they all get sick where they can't
get sold right or beef prices go like a
[ __ ] so people are gonna be like
well we want to eat healthy but at the
same time we want cheap prices it's like
you can't win I mean don't mass [ __ ]
have them like that like have clean air
conditions they have that like lab-grown
you you know right they have lab-grown
me but i don't know how it's a big made
a burger from it what if they what if
they create caps like if you're gonna
own if you're in the cattle industry or
the meat industry like you can have a
cap of only like 100 cows at a time and
then they can distribute the wealth that
way they could do that but they but the
cities are gonna write it when they go
to Ralph's and just the refrigerator
sections like this and there's one
ribeye they're gonna riot not only that
but then that's gonna make it super
expensive
plus it's like expect huge like lobby
groups for the length of the
catalytically there's I know wait art
art aren't they a subsidized industry
they are okay cuz you know your animal
stuff I don't I was like thinking corn
their subsidies yeah and soy but I don't
know about cow I don't know I don't need
any burgers on time I'm okay dude I wish
I didn't crave it I [ __ ] eat red meat
on a regular dude
yeah only started eating red meat a
little more recently yeah if I don't eat
red meat I can't get a boner well my
job's done here you needed in the dude
go with steak yeah [ __ ] man I live off
masters my life that's why people need
to take probiotics because all the mana
biotics be [ __ ] killing our
probiotics yeah they killed it good and
water right water is good too but you
think you get to do that no matter what
yo what the [ __ ] were you eating in
Jess's story you look like a garbage
Bowl that was a probiotic Bowl so I had
it looked like diarrhea with kimchi on
top of you I put kimchi
I put cabbage kimono I put not though I
have a raw egg I had uh umeboshi which
is a sour plum so like all these pickles
right pickled in slime yep that's all
kinds of probiotics can t eat it she'll
die
it looks like vomit yeah did you make
this [ __ ] up or do you smell like a
llama to something not don't worry I
like not those but his bowl look crazy
okay well the way I made it made it look
like vomit yeah
[Music]